you lose men
that's war sometimes the only way to
honor a fallen soldier
is to finish the mission
after years of fighting the war had
shaped us all
but the work wasn't over yet
the soe put me in charge of a new team
hand-picked for a top-secret mission
i'd led soldiers before but this group
were far more than that
lucas was an expert demolitionist who
had issues with authority
wade was the most dangerous thing in the
skies
never let you forget it
helena was the best sniper in russia
she wanted nothing
but vengeance
richard was my right hand
he always had my back
we were aimed at where our enemy was
most vulnerable
berlin is burning
from the ashes shall rise
our vision for something great
to the fourth right
risinger is leaving bottomland
he's taken the right underground
christ what is that smell
it's the smell of death normally there
are proper procedures to extract
information
we can end this bury the right for good
glory is worth nothing
when you are dead this fight
it matters
we were the vanguard
digital pre-orders get instant access to
the night raid mastercraft and operator
arthur kingsley